Lille in northern France has
traditionally been a stronghold for
France's Socialist Party meteorolo grew
up here he shows us around the suburb of
Waterloo where his parents still live
like many older residents here they came
from Algeria his mother's a cleaning
lady his father a factory worker shelah
became interested in politics when he
was just 15 one of my first political
acts was to tear down a poster featuring
former President Nicolas Sarkozy I
detested Sarkozy he called people here
trash that needed to be swept away so I
tore it down
he's always opposed making concessions
to the Conservatives that goes for his
fellow left wingers in Germany - in
Germany the Social Democrats say they
need to govern with the Conservatives
for the good of the country but that's a
mistake because Europe needs a common
discourse we need to say we will no
longer accept the status quo a Europe
that pleases the rich and crushes the
poor maybe Chawla himself grew up in a
poor family but he worked hard in school
and came here every evening to get help
with his homework so he was able to
study law at 17 he joined France's
Socialist Party it's been empowering
leader for decades and is renovating the
area made each ala grew up in though
even that he says won't level the
playing field for its residents as a
teenager it became clear how important
this association was to me because no
one could help me at home for kids whose
parents are teachers doctors or lawyers
it's a different story and that's simply
not fair he went into politics and moved
to Paris to work as an assistant for a
socialist MP but his political
aspirations were quashed during the
French parliamentary election of 2017
the socialists were decimated receiving
less than 6 percent of the vote
chilao wants to convince other young
people in the party that the Socialists
themselves
were to blame for the election debacle
he believes former president Francois
Hollande should have reacted differently
after the 2015 terror attacks in Paris
many in the Bourne you wouldn't observe
a minute of silence for the victims or
show respect and solidarity after the
attacks still the Socialists should have
listened rather than pointing the finger
and calling them racist because there's
something behind their actions they
don't feel part of France but at the
party's headquarters in Paris the
Socialists failed to acknowledge that
mistakes were made people here are more
focused on their impending move to new
premises their prestigious central
office building was sold due to a
significant drop in membership france's
youth were once fervent supporters of
socialist president francois metre hall
today the editor-in-chief of magazine
larva socialist as a pessimistic view of
the future if you're a socialist who
cares about the party there's not much
reason to be happy but it looks bad for
socialists all over Europe of course
we'll continue to exist but perhaps as a
small party that's dependent on others
it's a far cry from what we'd hoped for
many young socialists have joined
President Emmanuelle Merkel's party la
république or Marsh or drifted to the
extreme left but a small group is trying
to save the Socialist Party teacher
Maxine Baiul is among them he's a
village councilor who's continuing the
party's work at the grassroots level
he's strictly against forming an
alliance with McCowan's party today
McComb is a complete right-wing up he
makes right-wing policies that benefit
the super-rich at least in Germany the
young socialists position themselves
against the grand coalition
the young people were the only ones they
knew they'd have to sell their souls to
give them with Merkel in Leo MIDI Chawla
is convinced that the Socialists have a
future in France provided that the party
undergoes a radical restructuring before
we debate our political agenda
we must thought out how will reorganize
the party internally and he feels that
Germany's Social Democrats should do the
same to rejuvenate socialist parties and
politics across Europe